die mars mission exomars 2020 der
europäischen weltraumorganisation esa
ist geplatzt wichtige tests können wegen
der weltweiten corona pandemie nicht
stattfinden exomars ist also gecancelt
und auch im nächsten jahr ist diese
mission nicht möglich muss jetzt das
ganze projekt abgeblasen werden klicks
um science fiction die gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen clixoom gibt es jetzt
übrigens auch als podcast zum hören für
unterwegs die links zu spotify und apple
podcast sind unten in der video
beschreibung im juli 2020 sollte der
mars-rover rosalind franklin endlich im
rahmen der mission exomars zum roten
planeten staaten ab 2021 hätte er dann
schon über den mars boden rollen können
um dort nach leben zu suchen unter
anderem mit einem spezialbohrer
ausgestattet der bis zu zwei metern
unter die marsoberfläche schauen kann
außerdem mit an bord sollte der rufe
auch ein labor haben worin die proben in
einer reinen umgebung analysiert werden
können fachleute waren optimistisch mit
hilfe dieser mission endlich spuren von
leben zu finden dazu thomas zurbuchen
wissenschafts direktor der nasa der
landeplatz in jesu krater bietet ein aus
geologischer sicht reichen dort gibt es
informationen die bis zu 3,6 milliarden
jahre alt sind und möglicherweise fragen
zu planetare evolution und astrobiologie
beantworten können doch dieser traum ist
jetzt geplatzt das haben die
verantwortlichen verkündet dazu ein
sprecher von roskosmos der russischen
weltraumbehörde
wir haben eine schwierige aber gut
abgewogene entscheidung getroffen den
staat auf 2022 zu verschieben unsere
experten haben praktisch keine
möglichkeit reisen in partner industrien
fortzusetzen
denn natürlich wurden die treffen der
internationalen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler aufgrund der korona
pandemie abgesagt und so sind die
persönlichen treffen der europäischen
und russischen teams zeitnah nicht mehr
möglich doch diese sind unabdingbar um
die letzten hard und software tests
durchzuführen
der zeitplan für den start zum mars ist
damit dahin
so sieht es auch der direktor der
europäischen weltraumorganisation esa
johann dietrich wörner
wir wollen uns
100 prozent sicher sein dass die mission
erfolgreich verläuft wir können uns
keine fehler quote erlauben weitere
überprüfungsaktion täten sorgen für eine
sichere reise und die besten
wissenschaftlichen ergebnisse auf dem
mars außerdem sind ja viele grenzen
dicht und für die usa gibt es
einreisesperren für europäerinnen und
europäer auch das bedeutet ein problem
für das ex team denn auch der große
falscher mann dem der exomars rover
während seines abstiegs auf die
marsoberfläche hängt muss dringend noch
getestet werden
sie hatten sich in der vergangenheit
probleme aufgetan das ursprünglich
geplante fallschirm design hat er
versagt und es hätten sich risse
gebildet die testanlage in den usa
sollten laut plan eigentlich in diesen
monaten märz und april zeigen ob das
neue fallschirm design sicher ist fest
steht nur eine landung auf dem mars ist
alles andere als einfach insgesamt vier
fallschirme sollen den länder abbremsen
mit dabei zwei große haupt fallschirme
und zwei kleinere bremsfallschirme dazu
der exomars teamleiter france potteau es
ist sehr schwierig zum mars zu gelangen
und insbesondere auf dem mars zu landen
die dünne maße atmosphäre führt dazu
dass fallschirm und dort eine weitaus
geringeren bremswirkung haben als hier
auf der erde
dabei sind sowohl der rover als auch das
landemodul bereits mit allen
instrumenten ausgestattet derzeit laufen
nach angaben der esa aber noch tests in
frankreich war den untersucht werden
soll ob das ganze equipment den
bedingungen auf dem mars gewachsen ist
das neue start datum ist jetzt wie es
gerade gehört für den sommer 2022
angepeilt dann also soll der roboter
richtung mars fliegen denn dann sind die
bedingungen für ein start zum mars
wieder günstig in der zwischenzeit ist
der mars einfach zu weit entfernt das
ist übrigens schon das zweite mal dass
der aufbruch des rovers zum roten
planeten verschoben wird denn eigentlich
sollte der mars-rover rosalind franklin
der dem zweiten teil der exomars mission
darstellt schon vor zwei jahren 2018 zum
mars geflogen werden doch damals gab es
probleme mit dem russischen lande modul
2016 waren bereits der länder japan
rallye und der trays gas orbiter tokio
zum mars geschickt worden
doch nach der trennung stürzte tabarelli
aufgrund eines softwarefehlers ab der
orbiter dagegen kreist weiterhin im mars
orbit und könnte dem mars rover rosalind
franklin als relais zur erde dienen die
korona pandemie hat übrigens nicht nur
ausdrücke auf den start der exomars
mission sondern auch auf
unsere bereiche der raumfahrt die
agenturen laufen derzeit im minimal
betrieb der raumfahrt konzern
arianespace hatte mitgeteilt alle
geplanten raketen flügel vom startplatz
zu verschieben
expedition maß die gefahren und das
wagnis einer reise zum mars anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren und 2x kosmos
haben wir kanal mit langen richtig guten
dokus also ab pflicht für jeden der sich
für den kosmos interessiert bis dann
bleiben kann